you just came back from Antarctica that
was I watched the video that was that
was fun that was a really fun video
thank you
um
there's I mean there's a lot of things I
can comment about that but what was that
what was the hardest part of making that
video
the hardest part was just getting out
there it's just so remote and you know
you land the plane on just this ice
Runway and it's so sketchy and then once
the plane takes off you're just there
and you're the most remote place in the
planet and it's it's just it's very
breathtaking I don't if you have the
chance to ever go to Antarctica I would
recommend it it was probably like the in
the video we climbed a mountain
um that wasn't named so we can name it
and like standing on top of that
mountain and just seeing handling
nothing and because once you get outside
the outskirts and you get deep in
Antarctica there's no Penguins nothing
lives there at all
um and so there's just nothing in every
direction it's just snow and these crazy
beautiful mountains and some of them
sticking to the clouds and it was and
the um if you go during summer time the
Sun never goes down so the Sun's Up 24 7
and it's just like spinning in circles
at the top of the planet or whatever it
looks like top
um yeah you guys commented several times
how beautiful yeah and so it's just yeah
it's just very beautiful what about
shooting itself like the technical
aspects of shooting it oh I mean well so
somehow we locked down one of the days
it was like the warmest day in like
forever that's been in Antarctica it's
like it was positive uh degrees but at
certain parts there's also like negative
20 negative 30. and that's where the
cameras you constantly have to be
switching out the batteries and heating
them up and like putting them basically
in like your pants or they'll just get
way too cold and uh we were prepared for
much worse but it ended up being much
better than we thought